- Did you not hear that I
ruined Christmas recently?
- Oh, yeah, you did ruin Christmas!
- I was like, how did I mess that up?
- You guys are such, I know, I know.
Sharon Osborne, man, she
hates you guys. (laughs)
- She was just on my show!
And I was like, wait, what?
I was like, people got
so mad 'cause we changed.
He had this idea because
of the MeToo movement.
The pulled "Baby, It's Cold
Outside" from any radio.
Like, a lot of radio
stations at Christmas.
Well, I love that song.
- Well, yeah, but then Sharon assumed
that you guys burned them all
in the backyard or something.
They can never listen to
the original ever again.
- And both John and I have actually
cut "Baby, It's Cold
Outside," the original,
and we like the original,
but we notice that a lot of people didn't,
and so we were like, oh,
let's just give 'em
another option or whatever,
and apparently, we killed Christmas.
(audience laughs)
- You guys killed Christmas.
- I mean, I literally
woke up the next day,
and I was like, what?
- If I can't have
my creepy song,
it's not Christmas.
- I want the date rape dream.
- I want date-rapey songs.
- I was like, and honestly,
the original doesn't even offend me.
I just was like, cool,
we'll do another version.
- Exactly, like, I'm not offendable.
Like, I hear it all.
It's hard to offend me.
I wasn't mad about the song.
I don't care what you guys do.
But to be like, ooh!
I hate this now!
Oh my God, get over it.
- Yeah, it's so weird.
(audience laughs)
- Go on, Sharon.
- Go (laughs).
(audience laughs)
I love Sharon.
No, but here's the thing.
She actually said, and she
means it, like, she loves y'all.
That's why I thought
it was so weird, like,
she took it so personal.
I just thought it was weird.
But here's the thing.
I actually love her.
(audience laughing)
I do.
She came on here, and
I was like, I love her.
I think she's so funny,
but then I was like, we
didn't kill Christmas.
- You're nicer than me, man.
(audience laughs)
- Well, 'cause I'm
trying to understand it,
because I'm like, there are so many issues
in the world right now.
- No!
I want my creepy song!
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] It's so weird. Anyway.